son gain
[Musique]
laurent roselli et facteur depuis 13 ans
c'est par là
ce matin direction sainte-clotilde pour
sa tournée quotidienne
sous une île loin
laurent avait 24 ans quand son père est
mort emporté par la maladie
c'est quand il a commencé à travailler
comme facteur qu'il a réalisé à quel
point les réunionnais étaient attachés
aux chansons de son père souvent ce
matou renée il ya des gens qui me voient
remises et on a des coups quand bien né
figurent aux élus ou jeudi c'était mon
père et ça si tu veux sa force
ça m'a permis de d'aller vers les gens
et de partager avec eux ma passion et
mon héritage
[Musique]
voilà comment la a dit dimanche du mont
chaqra fait c'est bon vous écouter vidéo
quand il n'y à demi nue à samson depuis
avant qu'on à marilou mari nous avons à
nous rappelle l'époque là où ça nous les
invités à spa dans l'hymne est équipé de
réchauffer sa gran risa le coeur voilà
la pompe publiés ne me l'a même toujours
un mois mené l'étude
ben oui les mythos attali mais là il est
dans mon domaine comme ça va aller à la
banque
[Musique]
cinéma
même si nico
[Musique]
les gars ont fait sienne la musique
qu'on écoute dans le vent
théo à des écoutes à doubs avait le
meilleur est toujours spécial mais les
jeunes écoutent encore morsure
génération
voilà
soleil onana bombe encore il ça va merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
après sa tournée nous retrouvons laurent
roselli à saint-andré alors là tu vois
là on à la maison la maison familiale
la maison familiale à où j'ai grandi
fixer derrière la maison que pierre
roselli avait installé son studio le
fameux studio pyros aujourd'hui
complètement à l'abandon ces vieux vieux
vieux vieux il ya eu plusieurs plusieurs
plusieurs cyclones qui sont passés des
inondations du coup l'eau est rentrée
dans le studio
à voir l'état des locaux
on a du mal à imaginer que ce sont
écrites ici quelques unes des plus
belles pages de la musique réunionnaise
de michou à basse terre en passant par
micheline picot et danyel waro et moi
j'étais encore gamin j'étais comme ça et
moi j'arrive
moi j'arrive là imagine toi le camion
débarque là bas avec tout le matériel
le studio flambant neuf le piano la
guitare et à l'époque c'était ddd du
matériel pro de pointe quitté top à
l'époque a cédé non parce que je vois
tout çà est papa il me regarde moi je
suis là bas l'entrée mais fait nous
n'aurons pas à où aller là bas si vous
nous sommes allés là bas je pariais
telinge paris 1 parce que ça coûte super
cher tu imagines le truc matériel de fou
moi j'étais assis dans le coin là bas
j'étais assis dans ce petit coin là et
puis je bougeais pas et les artistes en
train d'enregistrer laban est partout
puis moi je ne bouge pas je regarde
comme ça et là j'étais émerveillé parce
que quand tu vois des musiciens comme la
sttr moi j'ai vécu
j'ai vécu l'enrichissement de basse
terre comme une magie dia l'horizon
casser cet été comment c'est possible de
faire la musique comme ça c'est une
révolution ou master
[Musique]
l'histoire
film ti amo
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
fil rouge dans les archives de rfo
laurent retrouve les premières chansons
de son père puisque le premier 47 à la
pierre aux lycées pas marino fait 40
sato qui a été enregistré avec les
playboys jules arlanda chemin
[Musique]
sa pierre roselli était un papa toujours
sur la route sur une autre planète
être
[Musique]
un père absent qui a tout de même eu le
temps d'apprendre à son fils le goût de
la musique et ses premiers accords de
guitare nous y voir au fait la musique
alors bon si on faisait des repas de
famille à chaque fois éprouvé sa guitare
il faisait petits morceaux et un jour
j'ai des prix une du temps et j'ai fait
j'ai fait avec lui et il chante et ses
mystères au coeur un certain tétouan sa
porte et m'ont tapé sur la table
demandant si c'est mignon tatataaa
est ce que tu es le c est ce que tu le
sais très peu diffusé tout le temps
cette boîte à chansons qui me qui me
reste donc forcément moi aussi j'ai
voulu faire sa ba ba tu veux faire comme
comme ton père je me souviens
dans la petite salle du carreau cannes
au théâtre de champ fleuri
laurent répète ce soir le spectacle
qu'il a décidé de dédier à son père
[Musique]
que la balle est privilégiée
les chansons les vieilles chansons qui
sont pas qu'ils sont pas connues mais il
faut aussi faire toi bien que le public
si tu as pas jouer demain - la main
marie l'odc mimi tous à table et ça ça
va être comme ça de la même ils vont
demander de poisson
[Musique]
dans sa colère
le venger avec ses chansons revisitées
on va de découverte en souvenir laurent
roselli chante un temps que les moins de
20 ans peuvent à leur tour comme être au
coeur de nos
[Musique]